[Music]
okay hello everyone so my name is Union
and for today
you know that the the USGS championship
um I mean was held here in St Louis and
um
amazing games were played and today I
want to show you one or two that I
consider were the best games
and also for for you to know like the
ideas
um openings maybe we can talk about
openings even though the probably the
middle game and the end game is the most
important in this game also those are
attacking games and like the principle
of the attack and
um like how Rey the first game is Ray
rock song against Wesley so how Ray
um he conducted this game in an amazing
way and also the opening was quite
interesting
so yeah so we'll I will start
D4
Knight F6
C4 E6 so well this is common and I think
Wesley usually
um
so he plays D5
uh against Knight C3 he plays D5 and
Bishop B4 sometimes
um this well white is obviously fighting
for for the center and this is the the
Nixon
so this opening is called the nexo nexo
Indian
and it's very interesting I actually
like with with uh with black I have
played this opening many times
main idea is to well then Bishop is pin
in the Knight but the main idea is to
trade the bishop for the night for the
Knight to destroy the white spawner
structure a little bit and put pressure
on the pawn on C4 like this Pawn usually
after this trade
like the bishop for the night then
um here
then the pawn on C4 uh becomes a
weakness this is usually one of the
ideas in this type of position
uh well yeah the X opponent C3 is
actually
um I mean it's actually good because it
supports the center
so
but because you have the pawn on C3 you
cannot defend the pawn on C4 and that's
why black will attack that weakness and
that's why that's usually one of the
ideas of the Nixon
now
um
so right play this E3
and I'm sure some of you will know this
opening
um with E3
solid players like this queen C2 which
is capablancas opening capablanca was
too positional and he didn't want to
give this chance the chance of
destroying his Pawn structure and so he
thought about a move like Queen C2 and
if Bishop takes Queen takes and then you
take with the queen so
itri is a ruinstein opening
and well we support in the center
um yeah black can take immediately here
but actually Bishop takes C3 is not the
main line here the main line is what
happened in the game
uh yeah you just play
um you said you play GIF Bishop G5 yeah
Bishop D5 is another idea Bishop G5
um I remember I have faced this move
and
um D6 here well you can play you have to
be careful when the bishop is on G5 to
play D6 because some Queen A4 Knight C6
and then some D5
um that you will lose a piece but
against Bishop G5 H6 is fine also B6 is
fine and then playing Bishop B7 which is
another idea in this type of openings to
play Bishop B7 and get the control of if
or
um E3
castles Knight F3
Bishop takes C3
here well
still possible
and but right now the main move is D5 so
this is the main line uh when y plays
Bishop D3 and then C5 this is
um actually the main line in this type
of position
so if castled there are a couple lines
here for black black plays Knight C6
well usually the idea is to also get
control of the center or a more concrete
variation which is this one and then B6
this is a more concrete variation and
black will play against them isolated
point which is usually the idea to block
that pawn and maybe go to an endgame and
take advantage of this weak point
but yeah this game was not boring so
Bishop takes
Pawn takes and now
after this trade okay black has the pair
of knights and
you want to keep the position as close
as possible that's why the idea is more
after you trade the bishop for the night
so usually in this type of position the
idea is more to play D6 E5 to get a
closed Center
ah D six okay Wesley played D6
and then our Bishop D3
well
um Ray is placed in the bishop in the
most active Square
but now uh the problem with this move or
it looks like there is a problem here
which is E5
it looks it looks black is sacrificing a
pawn here with this E5
but if Pawn takes Pawn takes Knight
takes
um anyway this point structure is not
great for white and eventually probably
this Pawn will fall also
um black will win some temples with that
move that's why against E5
um instead of taking material
right play this move E4 which is a
uh I mean this was not novelty there is
a game played by basily Evancho with
white and against Dean liren that a
bunch of one and they played the exact
same position
so E4
Rook E8
okay let's uh let's try to find to find
and figure out what to do against these
threats
now black is threatening Pawn takes and
Knight takes E4 so what to do
and also white is trying to get
Advantage which is something important
in this type of uh position in in
general in chess
okay so Punk pumpkin the cut says D5
uh okay I have D5 I have Queen C2
uh Bishop G5 three moves
and still I don't have the best move in
the position so D5 let's talk about move
by move so D5
um It looks interesting but you are
closing the position completely and you
have the picture pair now with D5 you
are also giving this C5 Square for your
opponent's Knight now after D5 this plan
is really strong and also the pawn on C4
will become probably weaker after D5
because after B6 Knight bd7 Bishop E6
Rook C8 airplane like C6 Pawn takes
will put a lot of pressure on these
Pawns
uh Quincy 2
that I mean looks more interesting Pawn
takes Pawn takes and then the problem
will be Knight takes E4
because if you take Bishop takes
then Bishop F5
92 I can trade and then F5
and this Pawn is uh hanging let me just
um
make the move to make it more like
easier to understand Bishop F5
attacking or also F5 is also fine but
Bishop F5 if Knight D2 then you take and
same thing I will play F5
and black will win a pawn in this
position
Bishop G5 on the other hand
um yeah I mean looks interesting after
H6 I don't think you want to take you
will probably want to play Bishop H4 but
Knight bd7 Knight f8 Knight G6 winning
tempos and closing the position more
and yeah so someone here
Lionel found the move castles now white
sacrifice sacrifices a Pawn on e4
and this is like a Gambit idea when you
sacrifice upon the idea is to win tempos
and you will use those temples so you
will develop your pieces quickly and you
will use those temples to convert them
in an attack so it will attack your
opponent's king your opponent's pieces
and that's actually what Ray did
in this position so
upon takes
Pawn takes Knight X E4 and the same
position was played in Evancho's game
here if we play Queen C2
this could be a transposition to the the
same line with Queen C2 let's say here
Queen C2
phone takes pontex Knight X E4 then
castles this will be a transposition
but
after
um castles Pawn takes pontex Knight
takes then white doesn't have to play
Queen C2
so white white can play rookie one
instead
Knight F6 and
when we are attacking and when we are
material down is is true that is not
good to trade off
like pieces and especially too many
pieces but in this case
um it's good to trade off The Rook so
that we can bring the other hook to the
open file also this rule could be a good
defensive piece in the king side
and so right trade groups in this
position
so Rook takes E8
Queen to xd8
Evancho's game I think yeah Knight X
um E8 happen in Evancho's game
and
after Queen C2 I think Queen C2
uh oh no no Bishop Bishop G5 was the
move so Bishop G5
then F6 Bishop D2
uh Knight D7 Queen C2 uh White got the
comfortable Advantage here
basically this position is
is slightly better for white even though
white is down upon
now let's go back
Queen takes E8 and okay I invite you to
try to find raid move
what should y play here so when we are
down a pawn we should
attack as quickly as possible but
sometimes we have to take some measures
foreign
[Music]
okay your DS Bishop B2
and then develop The Rook
okay so isuru what's your idea with that
move
because that might be might be the idea
thank you
yeah so it's sort of found the move so
H3
now what's the idea of this H3
who can tell me the idea of this move
and this simple move is
um I mean it's powerful in this position
so yes you stop Bishop G4 because when
you are attacking
you won
to attack with all your pieces and it's
the same thing with the when you are
defending so you mentioned D5 I think uh
pumpkin mentioned D5 well if D5 then you
are not stopping Bishop D4 I will play
Bishop G4
Bishop B2 and then Knight bd7
and my pieces look black pieces are
better coordinated and Bishop H5 Bishop
D6 to trade off this bishop looks like
uh like a very interesting plan after H3
Bishop H5 so
um
that's why
you play a move like A3 prophylaxis
then ibd7 and we can we we see how now
after this H3 what kind of problem a
black has well this Live Score Bishop
who
um of course Wesley wants to develop
this bishop but now it's not uh I mean
it's not a
um
I mean there is not a good good Square
you could develop E6 but then after
Knight bd7 D5 is a problem you could
develop the bishop well if these seven
Knight C6 then Bishop G5 and could be
some problems here so it's not so easy
to to find a good weight for the bishop
and what Wesley did was logical plane
ibd7
and then
um he wants to develop the bishop in
this diagonal
and
ER B6 Bishop B7 yes uh pumpkin that's
that's a plan and that was actually what
happened in the game now
in the so
Queen C2 was played and then B6 right so
Queen C2
the back rank is control the queen in C2
put pressure on this diagonal and now we
have
this Dar Square Bishop
and
okay the rule says we should place our
pieces that's in the middle game and
usually in engines too we should place
our pieces in the most active squares
now we have to find the most active
Square for this bishop
and Ray found the most active Square
now who can who could think about the
the
most active Square here
um I mean if I have to consider let's
see three moves
I could pick Bishop G5 looks active
maybe B2
and my third move will be probably D2 so
that you I can go and bring my Rook to
E1 so which one could be
uh Stronger for white
G5 looks interesting
um
now Bishop D5 if we bring the bishop to
G5 and then black continue with Bishop
B7
then we have this little problem like
the Knight because black is taken or
night and will destroy your opponent
structure
which means that okay we probably will
have to play D5
and black cannot move this Knight still
but then we will
have to think okay which diagonal is
better this one which is active too or
B2
and this one is more powerful
because the bishop control small squares
and at the same time you put pressure on
F6 same with the bishop on G5 but to
play Bishop B2
um obviously we have to find D5
so Bishop C D5
is the second best option see Bishop
here attacking here then D5 we have to
play this move otherwise Bishop takes
Knight
and right played this bishop B2
Bishop B7
here and well
um
we can't
allow black to take overnight so we have
to play
D5
and black played Queen f8 so Westlake
played Queen f8 why Queen f8
um he assumed that y will fight for the
file for the open file
and yes that's what usually we should do
when there is an open file we should
fight for the open file but in this case
this is not a good option
why why is not a good a good option well
if we place The Rook on E1
after Rook E8
then we will we will be trading pieces
and we don't want we don't want to trade
off pieces now
we have every piece developed and that
happens a lot in the Gambit every time
you sacrifice a pawn you develop your
pieces and now you have you have to find
something concrete
and that something concrete is attack so
you have to find a way to attack
sometime pieces sometimes your
opponent's king if it's your opponent's
king is even better so how can y
continue in this position because when
we are attacking and when we are let's
say we have our pieces active
we have to keep continuing with that
attack and and that what is what it
called uh is called initiative so we
have to continue with that initiative
so how should white continue in this
position
95 okay that's a good move to talk about
95
one night D5 is a good move okay 95 is a
good move if after H6 then you get
something exchange maybe after bringing
the Knight back then this was
um
a weak Pawn here but is that's not the
case or maybe you can sacrifice the
Knight or play on Knight H7 but
if you are not getting anything of that
then Knight D5 in any position is not a
good move
so G4 pumpkin and also Joshua found this
move G4
and this is the best move we have to be
very careful of open up or King side but
in this case white has everything under
control
now look how Mo like most white pieces
are attacking these Bishops
they both look powerful the bishop on B2
at the bishop on D3 too
um now what what's the threat here
yes this Knight on F6 and you want to
play this move G5
now there are two possible moves here to
play against this G5 threat
uh to face this fret one is H6 and the
other is G6
so which one do you think could be the
best one
so yg6
now thinking a little bit more defensive
in case things go wrong I don't know
okay and this is this is a good move to
to learn about because
we don't have that square Bishop
and or opponent
has a dotted Square Bishop
so if we play G6 here we are weakening
or dark squares Bishop that means that
this bishop even though we are giving
some room for the queen
this bishop
becomes extremely powerful and as a
general rule we have okay this is just
in general we have these two pawns we
need to move one of them
if we have that square Bishop let's say
Bishop only seven we will move this one
that's usually what would happen and if
we have a large-score bishop like like
it's the case we will move this because
then we can try to control the light
Square weaknesses but with D6
there is not opposition for this bishop
and
um after I don't know maybe Queen C3 and
this D5 is
um and like immediate threat so
yeah even King H2 could be good too so
that's why H6
uh must be played in these cases
now A6 well stops D5
when we are attacking we want as many
pieces as possible
um
yeah so you said that oh the H5 for the
night when you play H6 yeah but the
weaknesses so you're you're giving the
H5 for the night so this is for dark
tiger yeah you're giving the H5 square
if D5 in case of D5 but like the
weaknesses are too difficult to to lead
with and um after Queen C3
it's difficult to stop G5
yeah Twin City looks too strong maybe
after Queen C3 the only move I can think
of is Queen D7 like pinning yourself but
after G5 at least you have Knight H5
so that's probably
um yeah that's probably the best move
so here
now what to do so
uh G5 is still an idea
and we can continue the attack
so when we are attacking we want to
bring as many as many pieces as possible
now which piece and this is a principle
of middle game so which piece
um
like Hassan played yes yet
well this truck
so you want to uh
yeah so you said The Rook is kind of
slipping yeah it is so now but why which
square is the best one for the Rook
is E1 I mean is it this one no because
it's the same thing rookies so we need
to find a better Square for that rock
so where
should we put the Rook
F1 we will place The Rook in a uh in a
in a place when we can open a file
and then because the Rooks are extremely
powerful when we can open a file and
then attack with the Rook so we have our
pieces attacking and also a rook so we
can't
um open the f file but we can open the G
file so that's why Keen H2 to bring the
Rook
to G1 yeah it will take two moves
it will take two moves but once that we
place The Rook here then well black
can't stop that attack so it's too much
or will be too much
uh now
moving my roof next that's a good
question you are telling that to to your
opponent that's true but it's so so
strong that he can't do anything so he
just have to try to live with this Rook
G1 and all of these uh ideas but yes you
are basically telling that to your
opponent okay I will play Rook G1 I will
play G5 open up that file and then
um continue my attack so
just imagine if we move the Rook here
then G5 Pawn takes Knight takes we have
how many pieces attacking so deny The
Rook
two Bishops and a queen five pieces so
that's too much
now in this position because yes White
had to
um
had to lose a Tempo to play G5 and bring
the Rook to U1
now um Wesley missed a good opportunity
to kind of complicate things and maybe
equalize the game or or be at least in
the game still but he made the mistake
but the movie is obviously not obvious
so the move was I it is difficult to
find
um okay I will invite you to think for
maybe one two minutes and try to find
the best move for for black
when we are when we are attacking or
opponing is attacking us
um the first thing we need to think
about is to to counter play
and if our opponing is attacking us in
the king side which is the case here Rey
is attacking in the king side which are
we should counter play
in the center or
Queen side
because we probably will have better
pieces there
um okay pumpkin says Knight C5 Knight C5
is um
an interesting idea but you are breaking
your Pawn structure
um also which of F5 might work too
I have moved like here in the chat like
C6 and B5
and some of you said that you are not
sure about that move so yes one of them
is the move and they are actually both
doing the same or similar things so they
are trying to you're you're trying to
contemplate in the queen side or center
with both because B5 the idea is to take
and then take the sensor Pawn on D5
C6 the idea is to take the Central Pawn
D5 and ah
open up the bishop
so which one which one do you think so
which one do you think is the best move
here
C6 or B5
yeah B5 is the best move and it's not
obvious and the reason of why B5 is the
best move is that so what's like played
C6 but when you play B5
you are winning a temple
now if Pawn takes yeah if Pawn takes
Bishop takes D5
if
um B5 G5
now again C6 G5 black is forced to take
in this position you are not forced to
take you can take here
and you are winning a Tempo and still
white has some attack with Bishop F5
look how white instead of like taking
pawns is just go for the attack instead
of like taking material you focus on the
attack
because your big Advantage is here the
attack
and after visual F5 upon takes Knight
takes white has attack and but the
position is complicated
yeah you take on D5 I will bring my Rook
to E1 huge attack but this is the best
thing that that the best move for black
the best chance black hat
here well C6 happened
and after D5 now black is forced to take
or to take on D5
and open up the the bishop
so he wants to take on D5 open up the
bishop after G5 Pawn takes uh Knight
takes well after
uh Pawn text here is this is not obvious
what to continue with with white if Rook
G1 okay I can take here now
um is is this move different from the
previous position no it's difficult to
tell in in a position like like this one
it's too complicated
but then uh Ray found a nice
continuation here
to continue the attack
after King H2 and G5
one very interesting thing to to point
uh to point out here in this game is
that every move white played was an
attacking move so it was focus on the
attack the whole time creating threads
and it's usually what we should do we
should focus on the attack
okay you said c takes the fight rather
in Queen C7 but CTX D5 you are not
concentrating the attack and also Queen
C7
for now for now
um like isn't doing anything so if Pawn
takes like take Bishop D5 Queen C7
um like doesn't do
anything and also I could play Rook CA
winning a Tempo and remember we have to
try to
um to avoid losing temples okay yeah
someone here found the move
um attacked these six no actually you're
not attacking these six because the
queen protects this sex yeah the queen
is Island but still protects these six
yeah someone here in the chat found the
move the move is Bishop check
after King and shade then Bishop F5
see how like what's what's the idea well
the idea is threatening
Bishop takes and even if black protects
if Wesley protects the the Knight
I take here
Rook takes and then I take the other
Defender and then
the queen is coming to A7
so against Bishop F5 Knight E5
is mostly forced
then how can y continued attack
a wish Bishop
about where still H7 is covered by this
Knight
so even if you move the bishop to D7 or
even C8
so you're still are not threatening
anything on
uh what about this night
so yeah this Knight is not threatening
anything but
but the bishop the bishop is blocking so
the Knight is blocking this bishop and
this bishop it's um I mean this bishop
is extremely powerful so you want to
to put in in um in a yeah and
uh you want to bring as many pieces as
possible like Rook G1 but in this case
yeah so most of you have found here in
the move in the chart so it's F4 first
you play F4 you like you are kicking the
Knight out of E5
now then I have to either like take on
C4
or
play Knight G6
well the rule says if your opponent is
attacking you you should bring pieces as
many pieces as possible to the king side
even
if you have to give material
for that but
um so
if you take this Pawn
now all black pieces only the queen is
here in the king side are on the queen
side after Bishop takes Pawn takes Queen
E2
yeah it's practically a game over
Queen here The Rook is coming
game over so Knight G6
that's the best defense
and here
um so rate played
Bishop takes F6 but Rook G1 was probably
stronger because well you are bringing
more pieces into the attack and this is
this thread is always there
Bishop takes F6 so you can play this
move
um this move
is not good so and that you can take it
as a general rule when we are attacking
instead of taking material
we should concentrate more in the attack
so Bishop takes
here G6 let me talk about this move
again Pawn takes Queen takes
um I mean it looks fine you are
threatening Knight F7
but it's actually not a good move
why not
oh Dar tiger says that you play this
type of position
a lot well
you are lucky then because I mean white
is great here
kinsai attack with F4 and and D4 yeah
usually in the Sicilian when we play the
English attack we tend to uh play F4 G4
H4 and try to
push the pawn in the king side
so here what queen G8 Queen G8 Knight F7
and you're gonna lose your queen
but Queen E8 is a good move yeah Queen
E8
trading Queens if I can't trade off
Queens I'm fine probably more than fine
and after Knight F7 check King G8 I have
this threat
so even if Knight H6 check
Ed
and well block is fine here
so that's why so right took on F6
Pawn takes
and
how to continue the attack
also
um
I know that I said that it's not good to
trade off too many pieces when you're
attacking but in this case you are
trading an attacking piece for another
piece who is defending so it's not like
you are throwing this bishop for this
bishop who is isn't doing anything you
are training your Bishop for a knight
who is defending the king side so in
these cases you can do this this type of
things
now
uh Pawn takes
and then how should y continue here
because obviously Rey had an idea after
Pawn takes you are attacking the Knight
and that means that you have to continue
your attack you are not gonna take this
bishop and trade it for the Knight to
bring the Knight back this night back so
you want to keep the attack going
uh that that's true that's true that's a
good point uh so dark Tigers so that's a
good point so uh that dark tiger is is
saying that it's weird we play Rook Qin
H2 to bring the Rook to
yeah to you one and we haven't played
rookie one yet that's true here actually
you could have so Ray could have played
Rook D1 and was also a good move
probably even better the bishop takes F6
but Bishop takes F6 also wins and the
thing is we like every move we have
played before Rook G1 is better or have
been better than Rook G1 like for
example here
yeah white can play rookie one but
Bishop H7 Bishop F5 is better
uh 95
you can play Rook V1 but F4 is better
than Rook D1
96 and now is the the time when you
could have already could have played
rookie one here to continue the attack
but not a bishop takes Pawn takes this
variation is also fine
uh okay so
F7 Knight F7 I tag with the queen
but you could do something better after
Knight takes Queen takes
oh you can take the knife you can take
the Knight and that's
you get a pawn so you get a pawn for for
that trade and also
um besides of the pawn is it right so
you are trading another piece who is
defending the the king side and now the
the file is completely open
uh okay so darn nice is still searching
okay we just saw the uh I mean we we
um we're talking about the move so it's
Knight F7 sorry about that Knight F7
Quinta takes and then Bishop takes
um here
look that why trait well a lot of pieces
but now black like only has the queen
protecting the king side and the King
side is too open which means that we
there are weaknesses everywhere
uh Queen E7
and you will say okay now finally rookie
won but maybe even though this looks uh
logical maybe there is a better move
so which move could be better than Rook
G1
so I'm already saying that okay yeah
Rook D1 was not the move
uh that move Misha yes it's interesting
um
but not better than the move that
um
yeah Theodore agent you are always
you're also saying the same move
but
um
well rookie one so the queen is here
aware because then you have to be
careful you have to check me otherwise I
will have a lot of checks here
and someone some of you said Queen F5
Queen E2 we have to all the time we have
to be very careful of our opponent's
best move
every time and this is a very annoying
threat if we move the bishop like the
the queen sorry away of this defense
Queenie too then it will be Perpetual or
after Pawn takes we might be in trouble
with this powerful Bishop
so which other move
yeah okay Misha found the move
um who else McCarty also found it
yeah so some of you found this queen F2
now the idea is to bring the queen
to H4 and then finally bring the Rook to
U1
so only move for black F5 is I mean this
is practically the only move
to prevent Queen H4 now what should
white uh play
uh
okay dark tiger you were sent rookie one
right now well it looks stronger rookie
one I mean Rook looks strong but after
Queen F6
how can you use this this file you have
two open files ghee and E
okay so Bishop takes F5 looks an
interesting move too
but I mentioned before
that when we are attacking
instead of taking material we will focus
on the attack and create threads
so Bishop F5 yeah that
looks interesting
but you are losing a tempo
so how can you we use that Tempo better
that taking one point
well finally Rook G1
finally after like more than uh
10 moves maybe even more then
this will give one comes
basically here uh well black has to also
bring pieces into the defense of the
king side
and now
a very important move here for white
there might be more
um more than one way to win here
but this move is um
which one Queen D4
okay but what what if I go Queen G7
we don't want to trade off uh Quinn
right
so you probably will have to go back to
E3 or F2 and then Queen F6 and I think
the queen is black screen is better on
f6. E7
so
here you want to put pressure in open
files
and basically this is semi semi-open
file uh you have a pawn here but you
could take advantage of this too
and this is a completely open file
so
uh Theodore and Darth tiger who is
uh dark tiger is in fire on fire today
here yeah found the move
and the idea is quite clear
yeah black hasn't had the chance to play
pontax D the C4 because
um
he had to defend the key inside the
whole King side and now the thing is you
want to attack in this file on this file
and
Rogue G5 is the idea now you have two
threads one is Queen H4
the other is Rook H5
and Rook H7 so it's keyword
well basically there is only one way to
defend this position
and
who can tell me the only way to defend
the position for black because also when
we are attacking is extremely important
at any level to find our opponent's best
move at any level Grand Master Level
um even I don't know I don't know
amateur level we have to find our
opponent's best move no matter what
yeah so that's the only move rogi seven
I don't know but if someone says King G7
okay King G7 looks a really really risky
move
King G7 uh actually after King E7 that
he said I just saw a nice tactic this
bishop H7 check and if King takes you
give a beautiful checkmate
still after Bishop H7 you can take the
Rogue Pawn takes take the bishop but
Queen F5 and should be completely
winning for white
so
ah Rogue 7 only move
and
well the next move is clear Queen H4
check
King E8
now
even though because sometime happens a
lot I don't know if
that has happened to some of you when we
are attacking we usually focus on our
side and we try to find or like all
threats and try to we are we forget to
think that we have an opponent in front
of us who has a lot of could have a lot
of threats now one big threat is Queen
E2
so we have to keep the attack
and prevent this move Queenie too
okay how can we do that
image of H7 is interesting but after
Keen f8
how can you continue that
well no The Rook is paint
the queen yeah
yeah we can't play Rook G2 also Bishop
H7 Keen f8
to prevent the queen from coming his
point from coming back oh but if we
check here Keen effect and also we have
to be very careful of checking too much
when we are attacking because let's say
we started checking our opponent came
here then we check again kin goes Eva
and the king is almost in a good
position then after that so which means
that here
is weak
here is a strong so we should keep the
kin in the uh like weaker position
that's why yeah the best move okay some
of you found the move is Queen H5
we are covering this Square
now we are also calling the cane of this
cabin Square now the
um move that you said before Bishop H7
Rook takes F5 now my work because the
king cannot go to EA
so in the game Bishop C8 was what
happened
because ok
you have to protect the F5 Pawn now
what uh what happens if I take this pawn
and actually no black can't take the
pawn I remember some of you said that
okay that
um black
um hasn't had the chance to take the C4
pawn and yes so still there is not a
chance to take the pawn
but what happens how can I win
so this is a a nice puzzle this could be
those possible that you do in leeches or
chefs.com so why play and win
let's think for two minutes and instead
of giving me one move try to give me a
lot like the whole variation of moves
okay so my Curtis has Bishop F7 King f8
well but if you play Bishop F7 I don't
have to to play key in f8 I could take
on F7
okay dark tiger you forgot you have a
bishop on H7 when you checked maid on a
shade so you cannot play Queen a shade
because there is a bishop in in the
middle
yeah you forgot about that
and Misha you said check but instead of
kinashe they could go
uh kinfa too
oh you're sure there's something with
that move maybe uh Bishop you're so soul
is the same Bishop H7 and then Rook
takes and queen E8 yeah but it's black
to move too if Bishop H7 King f8 you
take on G7 and then I take with Queen
and you can't check my dominate
so Alex just has to Rook F5 right away
right now well if Rook F5
I mean seems interesting but after Rook
F5 actually
white is not threatening anything like
if Bishop H7 then I can take because
it's not pain so
now it might be another move so
okay
um I think Dark Knight
found an interesting solution so you
said Bishop A7 Keen f8 Rook takes F5
Rook F7 Queen H6 Checkmate okay the
first variation you forgot about the
bishop on H7 now you forgot about the
king the king can go E8
and it's not checkmate
Queen H6 skinny eight Bishop E6 or you
said Bishop D6 at the end instead of
Bishop E6
because uh Dark Knight the bishop is on
H7 yeah but if you do that you forgot
about the Queen the queen comes to E2
because it's not checked
so
okay
um no one has okay yeah Misha found the
the idea and the the winning move
so uh Misha here found the the winning
move
which is Bishop H7 check
the King goes to Faith then you take
Rook F7 and Dark Knight was thinking
about Queen H6 but the king is
going to the other way and Bishop D6 is
not on time because Queen E2 and the
queen is uh at least black has uh
perpetual and no probably it will be
Checkmate because King G3 I will
play check and you can't go H4 G4
I mean King G4 Queen check the king
should go H5 Bishop check King here
Queen check on F2 King D5 and then Queen
G3 checkmate
so we have to be careful
now the movie the the one that Misha
showed here which is Bishop G6
this amazing move
and
you are threading
queen of shades
so two threats
Rook F7 and queen shade
and white wings
so
I I mean I didn't show you this key in
h8 but it's too easy so you just take
kin V8
and queen H7 check
the King has to go to f8 because the
queen protects G7 and the king2 but
after Queen and Shake dude takes one of
those protections the King goes F7
you take here win the queen
the game continued Bishop C8
and now
instead of like continuing the attack
why white
um so Ray made this move point x this
simple move he's taking some pawns but
also black is almost in sixth one
like what can black do here
all pieces are like trapped
the king cannot go to the queen side The
Rook has to be there protecting here and
the queen has to be there protecting the
rook and protecting F7 if we bring the
queen to E3 for example then Bishop F7
check
and then we are taking the Rook
so it's almost six one well Westlake
played this move
and then
um
probably white is winning for with a
couple ways but Queen H6
looks good enough if Queen E2
or maybe this is the best move if Queen
E2 just wrote gito and The Rook covers
um the king also the queen on H6
is protecting F4 the pawn
so black can only move the Pawns
and here
um
maybe there are more than one
continuation to to win here
but um
the game finished with a nice successful
one
uh Bishop check
and why to move
Queen F6 how Queen F6 there is a queen
on on E7
ah Bishop F5 okay we cannot forget about
this thread Queen E2 because now we
can't Define with the Rook on G2
uh there is a rook on G7 so black will
take and after Queen E2 is perpetual
so yes uh t w w was the first one who
founded then Misha also found the move
uh in the movies
who else found the move
no I think only Misha and t w Rook D2
just this simple move
look that instead of taking this Pawn
like winning upon instead of that white
just
uh place this move
keep in the attack because when we are
attacking we don't want to trade off
um
pieces in general
but now white has a big big threat
and was that big threat
what what's uh White threatening now
The Rook is pinned yes
and we can take advantage of that pain
uh so one says Bishop G6 boy if you play
Bishop G6 I can go King E8
so and yeah Black season sixth one but
you want to make this move work Queen
and Shake if you go and play Queen and
shade Keen F7 and Rook takes D7 now how
can you make it work
um
yeah that that's the move
uh shortcut
and also picky found the move yeah just
Bishop takes F5
Bishop takes pawn and uh the queen goes
to h8 and there is not a way to stop
that threat so uh Wesley resigned in
this position even though they are both
equal like material equal but after like
Bishop F5 cannot be stopped so
yeah
and yeah it was um I I I believe was an
amazing game played by Ray
um
he played a very in a very aggressive
Style
and after that teenage two and D4 King
H2 every move was an attacking move
so I hope everyone enjoyed the game and
if you have any questions let me know if
you if you have any question
uh about the game or something in
general I will be happy to answer
thank you so much thank you yeah you're
welcome have a great day
okay no questions
so okay so I will see you all uh
tomorrow
yeah thank you
thank you again and thank you peachy so
we'll see you all tomorrow
[Music]